[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez pour cette nouvelle édition du
journal voici les titres de ce lundi 2
novembre jour de rentrée des classes et
journée d'hommage à samuel patier 17
jours après l'assassinât du professeur
une minute de silence a été observée par
tous les élèves de france à 11 heures le
premier ministre jean castex et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer air était d'ailleurs
présent ce matin à conflans sainte
honorine
une rentrée particulière également du
point de vue sanitaire en plein
confinement et avec cette nouveauté dès
6 ans les écoliers doivent désormais
porter le masque pour équiper les
enfants les communes yvelinois se sont
organisés exemple à elancourt et aviles
preuve et puis la france et les yvelines
ont vécu leur premier week-end de
confinement les sorties sont limités au
strict essentiel reportage lors d'une
opération de contrôle de la gendarmerie
invités de cette édition d'affiner
roumanie qui est secrétaire
départemental du snes fsu dans les
yvelines le syndicat d'enseignants du
second degré à un préavis de grève a été
à déposer jusqu'au 7 novembre pour
dénoncer et les risques de protocole
sanitaire mis en place dans les
établissements
[Musique]
une minute de silence observée à 11
heures en hommage à samuel pâtit ce
professeur assassiné le 16 octobre
dernier pour avoir montré en classe des
caricatures à ses élèves lors d'un cours
sur la liberté d'expression le premier
ministre jean castex et jean michel
blanquer air ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous l'avez vue sur ces images
qui étaient présents pour l'occasion à
conflans sainte honorine la ville où
s'est produit le drame c'était à l'école
élémentaire du clos d'ahaut minute de
silence observée partout en france et
dans les yvelines au même moment en
classe ces photos à poissy maurepas
trapon encore croissy sur seine
un temps suivi de la lecture de la
lettre de jean jaurès aux instituteurs
et institutrices est la journée qui
prévoyait initialement un temps des
changes entre les professeurs une
rentrée à décaler pour les élèves et un
hommage commun dans les cours de
récréation a finalement été revu à la
baisse crise sanitaire et contexte
sécuritaire oblige
et je vous le disais dans les titres je
vous le disais il ya un instant pour
cette journée d'hommage à jean castex et
jean michel blanquer arrêté à conflans
sainte honorine ce matin rencontre avec
les collègues de samuel pâti au collège
du bois d'auch les visites d'une autre
école élémentaire dans la foulée sur
place célia guettent son go et nicolas
landry c'est sous haute sécurité que se
sont rendus ce lundi matin vers 9h30 au
collège du bois donne à conflans sainte
honorine
le premier ministre jean castex et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer
pas de rentrée des classes pour les
élèves seuls les professeurs ont pu
discuter avec les deux ministres ainsi
que le maire de la ville laurent bros et
la rectrice charline à venelles deux
semaines après le meurtre de samuel
pâtit jean castex et jean michel
blanquer air se sont rendus par la suite
à l'école primaire voisine le claude en
eau toujours à conflans sainte honorine
pour observer la minute de silence
avec un peu de retard ils ont chanté
avec des élèves de cm2 la marseillaise
[Musique]
à la sortie des classes les élèves et
leurs parents continuer les échanges
on en parlait pas de samuel patxi on a
travaillé dessus on parlait de la de la
liberté d'expression je pense que c'est
très très important de dollars expliqué
justemment ils savent pas qu'ils peuvent
être manipulées par n'importe qui donc
c'est l'école qui doit expliquer les
valeurs tout le corps enseignant étaient
représentés et soutenu ce lundi matin
on est avec l'équipe enseignante et
l'équipe de direction très sont dès
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le temps de
l'hommage et après le temps de l'hommage
vient le temps des actions concrètes le
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine
laurent bros va initier une concertation
avec la communauté éducative les
associations de prévention spécialisée
et les communautés religieuses
l'idée c'est vraiment que nous puissions
intervenir au coeur des partis et des
quartiers au plus près des familles pour
qu'on puisse les accompagner les aider
pour qu'on puisse écouter écouter ces
familles écouter ses élèves à conflans
sainte honorine un lieu sera également
dédiée à la mémoire de sympathie et avec
mon physio delphine romani bonsoir
bonsoir secrétaire départemental du snes
fsu dans les yvelines c'est le syndicat
d'enseignants du second degré on parle
dans un instant avec vous de ce préavis
de grève est déposé par l'intersyndicale
composée notamment du snes fsu pour
dénoncer à les risques de protocole du
protocole sanitaire mise en place dans
les établissements déjà revenons sur
cette journée d'hommage forcément
particulière on imagine pour les
enseignants une journée d'hommage on le
sait qui a été remodelée par rapport au
programme initial en raison du contexte
sécuritaire et sanitaire
certains professeurs ont ont dénoncé je
cite un hommage sacrifiés est ce que
vous vous êtes sûre sur le même plan est
ce que
vous estimez que cette journée a été
sacrifié cette journée d'hommage
alors oui effectivement nous on a très
rapidement dénoncé le revirement du
ministre qui a été énoncé en courant
d'après midi vendredi c'est à dire de
manière bien trop tardive pour pouvoir
organiser les choses
la demande du snes fsu c'était depuis le
début qu'il y ait un temps de
concertation entre adultes pour pouvoir
préparer cet hommage pour voir aussi et
d'abord partager notre émotion entre
adultes puis ensuite préparé l'hommage
est préparé les élèves expliqué aux
élèves le sens de l'hommage tout ceci
n'a pas été possible n'avait pas eu le
droit à ce temps banalisation de
concertation entre adultes la minute de
silence s'est réduite à simplement ceci
sans explication sans pouvoir faire de
la pédagogie
certains enseignants ont fait le choix
d'être en grève de 8 heures à 10 heures
pour préparer cet hommage d'union avec
les élèves
donc vraiment concrète profondément de
ne pas avoir été écoutés et d'être d'en
être arrivé là
il en coûterait 100 pédagogique ce temps
républicain il est primordial pour vous
alors le ministère de l'éducation
nationale a dit qu'ils pourraient se
tenir dans le courant du mois de
novembre
pour vous c'est essentiel que ça puisse
se tenir aujourd'hui la difficulté c'est
que une minute de silence en fait ça ne
fait pas sens pour un certain nombre
d'adolescents dans les petites classes
au collège donc il fallait expliquer
pourquoi cette minute de silence
pourquoi elle se fait la lecture de la
lettre à jean jaurès
c'est du même ordre il faut expliquer
qui était jean jaurès quel était le
contexte historique
tout ceci en fait c'est complètement
incompréhensible pour des adolescents
aussi si ça n'a pas été préparé donc
finalement cette minute de silence dans
certains établissements s'est réduite à
pas grand chose
et nous on trouve on à dénoncer
l'indignité de l'organisation de ce
temps qui devait être un hommage à un
collègue qui rappelons le a été
assassiné parce qu'il faisait son métier
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de
collègues qui ont été en grève le snes
fsu en intersyndicale mais qui est
composée notamment du snes fsu a déposé
pour aujourd'hui jusqu'au 7 novembre un
préavis de grève pour dénoncer les
risques de protocole du protocole
sanitaire mis en place dans les
établissements
je cite c'est pour défendre la santé des
personnels et des élèves
il n'y a pas eu assez de temps à votre
sens pour préparer cette rentrée on l'a
su aussi avec les annonces du président
du premier ministre une rentrée avec un
protocole renforcé n'y a pas eu assez de
temps pour la préparer alors
effectivement d'une part elle a eu
connaissance du protocole uniquement
jeudi soir donc c'est extrêmement tardif
pendant une période de vacances pour le
mettre en place
d'autre part ce protocole n'est que
prétendument renforcée puisque en fait
il est indiqué à de nombreux endroits
que les mesures sont préconisées et puis
si ce n'est pas possible eh bien on
continue comme avant donc pas parler de
protocole renforcé et enfin ça tombe des
mesures qui sont préconisées sont
complètement inapplicable
c'est à dire que par exemple les mesures
de distanciation physique si on ne
diminue pas le nombre d'élèves présents
dans l'établissement
elles sont en fait complètement
impossible à mettre en place puisqu'on
peut pas simplement pousser les murs
pour agrandir les locaux con qu'on soit
bien clair delphine roumanie où vous
n'êtes pas contre le maintien de
l'ouverture des écoles malgré malgré ce
nouveau confinement c'est uniquement
avant un protocole un peu plus clair
c'est ça que ce que vous demandez
aujourd'hui alors nous effectivement ce
qu'on souhaite c'est maintenir les
écoles ouvertes parce que l'expérience
du printemps dernier nous a montré que
l'école à distance avec creuser les
inégalités sociales donc nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est resté ouvert le plus
longtemps possible et ce que l'on craint
c'est que si des mesures adaptées
approprié qui sécurise tous les élèves
et tous les personnels
maintenant si ces mesures ne sont pas
prises effectivement nous allons en
arriver à une fermeture totale des
établissements très rapidement donc nous
comprendre c'est un protocole beaucoup
plus strictes et beaucoup plus
sécurisant préavis déposés jusqu'au 7
novembre et ce qu'il ya déjà des
discussions en cours est ce qu'une
rencontre est prévue avec l'éducation
nationale ou pas du tout alors pour
l'instant non il ya un certain nombre
d'établissements qui était déjà déjà en
grève aujourd'hui les lycées de
mantes-la-jolie saint-exupéry et rostand
le collège chénier les bd grévistes
aussi à jean monnet à la
queue-lez-yvelines le mouvement de grève
va se poursuivre demain et mercredi on
appelle à une grève massive jeudi et on
espère on sera entendue puisque des
solutions existent elles ont été
proposés les chefs d'établissement sont
à l'écouté
ils entendent les demandes des
enseignants certains les soumettent à la
direction académique
donc nous espérons être écoutés merci
d'être une roumanie
merci secrétaire départemental du snes
fsu dans les yvelines
une rentrée particulière donc en plein
confinement il ne rentrait masqué
également pour une grande majorité des
élèves le port du masque est dorénavant
obligatoire dès 6 ans une casse tête
pour les parents à qui ont dû se fournit
en protection dans le week end certaines
commune yvelinoise de leur côté ont fait
le choix de venir en aide aux familles
reportage à elancourt et villepreux avec
astrid bergère et mélanie pau qui a elle
encourt huit mille masques ont été
fournis aux enfants un coût financier
pour la commune mais nécessaire c'est
très lourd je rappelle que la compétence
santé général c'est l'état c'est pas les
collectivités mais bon on doit faire
face nous on est à proximité des des
gens on voit alors leur inquiétude
surtout les enfants
il faut être présent il faut résoudre le
problème voilà en tout cas ce effet
prévenu jeudi difficile de s'organiser
pour les parents cette aide est donc la
bienvenue
c'est gentil ça nous aide parce qu'en
dernière minute on en avait pas donc
c'est pas plus mal
ils l'ont fait aux premiers confinement
pour nous donc c'est gentil de le faire
pour les enfants aussi très bien qu'elle
a vu le distribuer des masques parce que
c'est pas évident de se trouver des
masques enfants comme ça du jour au
lendemain un vip rue 1800 masque
lavables ont été commandés par la ville
chaque élève de l'école élémentaire en
aura deux s'étaient pas obligatoire
effectivement mais on savait et ça a été
dit que l'éducation nationale n'avait
pas prévu de doter l'ensemble des
enfants en masque éventuellement plutôt
les familles fragilisées ou qui était le
plus dans le besoin
nous nous avons décidé d'aider
l'ensemble des familles proviennent et d
accompagner donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on n'a pas tergiversé on a
décidé très tôt dès jeudi matin de
passer commande et les maths sont
arrivés vendredi soir
certains étaient déjà équipées d'autres
pas mais la majorité des parents
présents à la sortie de l'école apprécié
ce coup de pouce
nous on en avait acheté parce qu'il en
avait déjà parlé mais c'est vrai que la
mairie a fait un gros geste vis-à-vis
des enfants
c'était donc une rentrée particulière
pour les enfants reste à savoir s'il
supporteront le masque toute la journée
[Musique]
l'autre actualité du moment c'est bien
sur ce nouveau confinement qui a débuté
depuis vendredi ses conséquences aussi
la fermeture de certains commerces des
commerçants qui dénoncent de leur côté
la concurrence déloyale de la grande
distribution et dimanche soir le premier
ministre jean castex a finalement
annoncé que les grandes surfaces allait
devoir fermer leurs rayons non
essentiels dit demain mardi réaction
avec des commerçants yvelinois un sujet
de justin brasier dès mardi les produits
considérés comme non essentiels ne
seront plus accessibles
si plusieurs commerçants ont déjà fermé
au début du confinement
c'est le tour des grandes enseignes de
fermer certains de leurs rayons
notamment textiles jouets ou encore
culturels une décision annoncée par le
premier ministre jean castex ce dimanche
1er novembre pour être équitable
la mesure ne convainc pas en fait c'est
pas ça que les librairies françaises
souhaitée c'est plutôt que nous on
rouvre côte d'ivoire est indépendante on
roule parce qu'on est tout à fait à même
de savoir gérer un flux de personnes
dans une halle berry avec des jauges
avec les barrières sanitaires
respectez donc la demande de l'héberger
française n'était pas du tout dans le
sens de il faut interdire la lecture aux
gens c'était plutôt d'accéder à notre
demande d'ouvrir la librairie
indépendante dans l'incompréhension face
à l' annonce du premier ministre jacques
creyssel délégué général de la
fédération du commerce de la
distribution a réagi sur twitter
la seule vraie solution est de permettre
rapidement la réouverture au moins sur
rendez vous des petits commerces
nous sommes par ailleurs près magasin
par magasin et via nos sites à les aider
à développer leurs activités de click
and collect jouons plutôt hashtag
gagnant gagnant certains magasins eux
ont pu garder leurs portes ouvertes
considéré comme essentiel c'est le cas
notamment des enseignes vendant du
matériel électronique nécessaires au
télétravail
on peut avoir une urgence un appareil
qu'il y ait une imprimante là qu'il nous
a lâchés oui c'est important parce que
j'en ai besoin
maintenant si darty reste ouvert et que
le petit fournisseur de matériel
électronique lui ferme
c'est un peu plus compliqué oui c'est
important pour moi aujourd'hui
maintenant il faut que focki une égalité
de traitement
si les click and collect ont été mis en
place par la plupart des commerçants ils
sont inquiets que la situation ne
profite au site de commande en ligne
l'action commune des sept présidents des
départements franciliens dont les
yvelines ils ont écrit une lettre
commune au premier ministre jean castex
dans celle ci les élus s'inquiètent des
conséquences du confinement sur
l'économie locale et le commerce de
proximité
ils demandent au chef du gouvernement de
permettre au préfet de pouvoir rouvrir
localement certains commerces sous
condition de constater le respect des
mesures sanitaires sur place lé
président ne saurait ce ne serait se
résoudre je cite à la disparition d'un
grand nombre de petites et moyennes
entreprises qui maillent notre
territoire et participe à la qualité du
lien social fin de citation ce week-end
c'était donc la fin des vacances de la
toussaint mais c'était aussi le premier
week-end de confinement de ce deuxième
confinement du côté des habitants cela
induit forcément des changements
d'habitude dans les modes de vie à les
moins de moins de sorties moins de
contacts aussi comment les yvelines ont
aussi organisé leur premier week-end de
confinement comment vont-ils s'organiser
pour la suite micros tendus dans le parc
des sources de la bièvre et guyancourt
par eléonore sinoquet là aujourd'hui
juste une balade vraiment une balade
sans vraiment de s'aérer de profiter de
ne pleuve pas mais c'est vraiment la
balade
j'ai prévu du bricolage ou et voilà des
choses que l'on remet toujours et puis
là en fait on a un peu le temps de faire
et voilà donc on s'organise et puis on
fait des choses qu'on n'a pas tellement
l'habitude on se remet un peu la lecture
je vais en profiter pour lire
puis travailler un petit peu comme je
suis enseignante je vais continuer à
travailler avec mes élèves
on a d'abord fait a quand même des
petites courses histoire de vérifier que
ça fonctionne et qu'il ait pas de
pénurie donc ça ça marche bien j'ai pu
faire les choses à pied pour prendre le
temps de marche il ya télétravail marche
plus du tout prendre soit à pied soit à
vélo pour faire les courses
la seule chose que je peux faire me
promener
dans le parc à côté de chez moi et sinon
bouquiner et puis cuisiner en un jeu de
sport un peu des courses il va cuisiner
on a retrouvé les vielles habitudes et
en ce premier week-end de confinement
plus de 100000 contrôles ont été
réalisés en france 5000 amendes dressées
et l'honneur sinoquet a suivi une équipe
de la gendarmerie dans les yvelines il
était en opération à samedi soir du côté
de cheval attestation dérogatoire ou
attestation professionnels en ce premier
week-end de confinement c'est de
pédagogie et de discernement dont a fait
preuve la compagnie de gendarmerie de
saint germain en laye on va avoir des
services vraiment dédié à ces
restrictions un petit peu de circulation
et de respect de ces règles de
confinement avec notamment le le
contrôle des attestations puisqu'il ya
trois types d'attestation maintenant
qu'ils sont mises en place et les
contrôles donc vont être vraiment
intensifiée à partir de lundi puisque la
période je dirais un petit peu de de
pédagogie pour ce week-end et de
tolérance se sera passé
donc on agira sans doute avec un petit
peu plus de fermeté mais toujours avec
le discernement nécessaire achats de
première nécessité déplacements
professionnels ou médicaux les
dérogations sont sensiblement les mêmes
que lors du premier confinement mars
dernier pas toujours bien ancrée oui
c'est normal en fait je tourne et dehors
on est censé ne pas être dehors donc
c'est normal pour moi qu'est ce que vous
faisiez justement barre en fait on est
partis mettre de l'essence mais font
leur travail l'emploi de soucis faut
respecter le confinement ces mêmes
règles pour tout le monde c'est normal
ça ne dérange pas c'est ils font leur
travail et c'est logique mais d'après
qu'est ce que j'ai entendu et qu'est ce
que je vis plutôt que
il ya beaucoup d c'est beaucoup des gens
malades et qui sont en réanimation
ce soir là la compagnie n'a pas dressé
d'amande lors du premier confinement les
forces de l'ordre avaient dressé plus
d'un million de contraventions pour plus
de 20 millions de contrôles le récit de
mélanie poké est les forces de l'ordre
qui ont dû faire face dans les yvelines
à de nombreuses échauffourées ce
week-end en ce week end d'halloween
samedi c'était la soirée d'halloween
vous le voyez un bus de la ligne 2 172
de la ratp qui a été incendiée par deux
hommes à l'arrêt romain rolland à
sartrouville aucun blessé n'est à
déplorer
un chauffeur de bus a été également
agressé du côté de chanteloup les vignes
où les policiers ont aussi essuyé des
tirs de mortiers tout comme à poissy aux
mureaux jets de pierres et jets de
nourriture à montigny le bretonneux un
policier municipal qui a été blessé au
genou écoutez la réaction de julien le
cam représentant du syndicat alliance
police nationale
on a vécu un premier week-end de
confinement très particulier avec
justement le contrôle des attestations
des violences urbaines et jus le
week-end de la toussaint où il fallait
sécuriser les édifices religieux et les
effectifs ont été très sollicités ce
week-end le confinement est pas
respectée mais c'est vrai que là il ya
une explosion des violences urbaines
comme sur la première période de
confinement qu'on a connus donc de mars
à mai dernier où tous les quartiers
difficiles du département ont été
victimes donc j'ai eu de violences
urbaines durant tout le week end
on constate que nos responsables n'ont
pas pris la mesure de ce phénomène et
nous ont pas renforcé en effectif une
nouvelle fois à la rentrée de septembre
et donc on peut le ressentir un mes
collègues sont à flux tendu sur le
terrain manque d'effectif mais également
il faut savoir que les services de
police sont touchés par le cos vite 19
donc on a beaucoup de collègues aussi en
arrêt maladie et les effectifs sont très
très sollicité et dimanche pour le
week-end de la toussaint les événements
ont pu se rendre au cimetière malgré le
confinement
reportage au cimetière des gones arts de
versailles avec elle au nord si nos
quais et justine brasier autorisé à
fleurir les tombes de leurs proches
plusieurs personnes ont profité du week
end de la toussaint pour venir se
recueillir comme ce dimanche au
cimetière des gones arts de versailles
je suis partie rendre hommage à mes
arrière-grands-parents donc du coup
c'est important surtout en cette période
en fait donc du coup voilà je suis venu
je suis de mon goût de bon matin pour
déposer des fleurs sur leur trouve on
vient assez régulièrement mais où the
way c'est la coutume
qu'est-ce qu'on puisse venir en dehors
de la tout ça mais on aime bien venir ce
jour là
contrairement aux premiers confinement
les cimetières devrait rester ouverts
une décision importante selon les
visiteurs pour pouvoir être dans
l'ambiance du cimetière de se rapprocher
des tombes les d'abord de les nettoyer
aussi de voir toutes ces jolies fleurs
de voir que tout le monde pense à ces
morts la semaine je travaille donc je
suis pas venir donc c'est très bien que
c'est ouvert le samedi dimanche et je
l'a tous appartement après ce week-end
de la toussaint il sera donc possible de
se rendre au cimetière
en cochant la case motif familial
impérieux de l'attestation il ya dans un
instant on retrouvait le 7-8 sport avec
cette information largement développés
tv 60,18 vous l'annonçait la semaine
dernière le tour de france passera
encore par les yvelines dernière étape
du tour 2021 au départ de chatou le
parcours officiel de la grande boucle a
été dévoilée hier dimanche 21e étape qui
sera au programme le 18 juillet prochain
112 km direction est les champs-elysées
à la commune de château qui avait déjà
accueilli une épreuve cycliste celle du
paris nice c'est et en 2018
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]